I'm looking at you right now and I have
a question yeah it's about your hair
yeah um I'm noticing it's long yeah
it's getting long in front yeah I'm fine
that is a guy all you have to do is take
one of those buzz razors you know and
you can kind of neat it up a little on
the side and then let me see the other
side
what yeah I see you bust it there uh-huh
buzz it there a little bit and also then
what happens is I often do that when I
get out of the shower you do a little
there and then you look down at the
chest and you go might as well and you
start working on the chest a little bit
here anymore it's fine oh this is gonna
get long and then it's gonna it's gonna
come forward like some kind of a
mythical beast it's gonna come forward
like that in the following Conan let me
tell you what you could do it's gotten
so long now you could do well there are
two things you could do one is you could
do it like a samurai get a hair thingy
dingy yes and do a samurai that would
look kind of neat I think okay or you
could get a barrette and you could pouf
it and barrette it and you would have
Elaine hair from Seinfeld
oh look like Elaine Benes on Seinfeld
that's my dream